will there be three more years of joe
biden uh it's very unclear actually
because joe biden's vice president
kamala harris she was on nbc being
interviewed about what perhaps
they might do in 2024 are they going to
stick it out and keep going is she going
to take over what's going to happen have
they even thought about it are we going
to uh to see the same democratic ticket
in 2024
i'm sorry we are thinking about today i
mean honestly that i i know why you're
asking the question because this is the
part of the punditry and the the gossip
around places like washington d.c let me
just tell you something we're focused on
the things in front of us
we're focused on what we need to do
to to address issues like affordable
child care what we need to do
conversations about 2024.
the american people sent us here to do a
job and right now there's a lot of work
to be done and that's my focus sincerely
you're at least familiar with some of
the punditry i don't know if you've
heard that there have been some there's
been some talk about a a a binding
cheney ticket perhaps in 2024 did you
read that article i did not i
no i did not and i really could care
less
about the high-class gossip on these
issues okay first off everything she
said there was a lie they obviously are
thinking about it they're obviously
talking about it this is what
politicians do you get into power and
then you figure out how you can stay in
power so of course she's lying and
anyone that says that they're not
thinking about their next election is
always lying she also said she could
care less what she means is she couldn't
care less that's one of my biggest pet
peeves you know she couldn't care less
if you couldn't care less you can't care
about it any less i don't care about it
all but he says well uh biden might run
with liz cheney i could care less oh so
you do care
i just can't stand that it drives me
nuts um also i haven't read that article
about biden maybe running with liz
cheney but does that tell you everything
you need to know about liz cheney she's
not a real republican obviously she's a
democrat
she's awful
anyway
there is a chance now that hillary may
get into the race that's the new talk
because basically what's happening is
that when you look at biden's approval
numbers and his age and his cognitive
decline and everything else and then you
couple it with a woman who was polling
at zero percent in her own party like
nobody there simply is nobody that
supports kamala harris there is just
nobody out there there yes media people
put stories about her but there is no
average human being that
that is supporting kamala harris so the
democrats have to figure out what to do
right so now suddenly there's all these
stories popping up will hillary get back
in the race uh we've got a little info
here from the new york post could a
third time be the charm for hillary
clinton that's the case made by two
prominent democrats who claim a perfect
storm
of president biden's plummeting job
approval ratings vice president kamala
harris's own unpopularity and the
commander-in-chief's advanced age could
provide an opening for the former first
lady and the secretary of state
she is already in an advantageous
position to become the 2024 nominee
democratic nominee political consultant
doug shone and former manhattan borough
president andrew stein write in
wednesday's wall street journal of the
74 year old clinton she is an
experienced national figure who is
younger than mr biden and can offer a
different approach from the disorganized
and unpopular one that the party is
currently taking they had if democrats
lose their house and senate majorities
in november's midterms schonenstein
argue clinton can capitalize on the
losses as a basis to run for president
again enabling her to claim the title of
change candidate okay let me just say
the article is mostly nonsense because
74 and she's going to be the change
candidate yes hillary clinton is going
to come in and be the change candidate
she's so young at 24 right like at 74.
man we could use a 24 will be can't be
president of 24 year old
but
it was making me think it was making me
think why would hillary run now we know
she's lost twice but it's not just that
there might be some other reasons she
might not run i mean does hillary
clinton believe in the validity of our
previous elections we've got a
compilation you know every time donald
thinks things are not going in his
direction he claims
whatever it is is rigged against i know
that he knows that this wasn't on the
level this is this is how donald thinks
and it's funny but it's also really
troubling i believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons
why the election turned out the way it
did he's an illegitimate president
and because of that he is
he's he's very uh insecure about it of
course he's obsessed with me oh hillary
i'm sorry i probably ruined all your
lunches but i haven't even listened to
that ridiculous woman but it's just
interesting to know that you know when
the democrats question election validity
when they say that someone's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
something happened he knows what was the
other one that the election it wasn't on
the level of course she's talking about
the election that she lost remember
you're allowed to do stuff when you're a
democrat you cannot do it when you're
republican or anyone who isn't just sort
of a brainwashed blue-pilled
npc
person